The Race Against Time continues on the
malikesh dev Street in karaman marash
it has been more than a hundred hours
since the massive earthquake struck here
but rescue Force are still frantic
Fatma second ways of grief singing for
her loved ones
[Music]
my niece is there five days without her
voice she says
every second matters in the race to save
lives
here hope is intertwined with pain as
bodies after bodies keep arriving
has waited here for five days hoping to
find her four children alive
now two of them lay lifeless on the
floor next to her the remaining two are
still missing
may God punish those who constructed
these
collapse and whoever didn't respect them
families keep waiting here anxiously
throughout the day and night some of
them just to get the bodies of their
loved ones
zacharyabah had to witness his wife and
son die slowly as they remained stuck
under the debris
I was under the rubble for five hours my
son was screaming and saying father
we're dying his mouth was full of dirt
he couldn't breathe properly I crawled
towards him and he told me dad I love
you he died there now I'm waiting for
his and my wife's bodies
rescue teams are calling for silence
trying to track a voice they heard from
under the rubble
they must be quick but careful before it
fades
people pray and hold their breath
a moment of joy for a hopeful family and
others around as Rescuers pull out the
disabled 35 year old Chasm Tatar
after nearly 110 hours on the rubble
a moment also celebrated by The Rescuers
[Music]
after five days under the rubble We
rescued him now we need to continue to
work
store that
Chasm tells of another man that was
stuck next to him under the rubble and
was still alive another spark of hope
and the work restarts
as the sun sets The Rescuers
relentlessly continued their search